(dramatic music)
- Welcome to the Think Marketing Show,
the number one podcast
for growing and scaling your
business with online video.
I'm Heather Torres.
- And I'm Sean Cannell
and we're from Think Media,
and if this is your first
time listening, welcome.
- This show is dedicated
to helping you learn
how to get your content noticed,
and the latest money-making strategies
working right now on line.
So whether you wanna
grow your YouTube channel
or maximize online video
across social media,
this is for you.
- So today, we're talking about
how to stay consistent on YouTube.
This is something I struggle with Sean.
- Yeah.
- And to be completely
honest, it's because
I use the excuse of time.
That's my big excuse and so I want you
to bust through my excuse today
and give us four reasons or four ways
to stay consistent on YouTube.
First of all, why does consistency matter?
- Yeah so, consistency on YouTube is tough
but consistency in anything
that's a challenge is tough.
And why does it matter?
Well consistency is what's
required for credibility.
Consistency is what's
required for building trust.
Consistency helps you build momentum
and when you aren't consistent you lack
those essential ingredients of success.
Like a business that doesn't
have trust, or momentum,
or credibility is not gonna
be a successful business.
And people, we want to, often times,
have the rewards of a
successful YouTube channel
without doing the work
that it takes to get there.
And so, being consistent
starts a little bit
with counting the cost and also though
considering the reward.
Like the reward of consistency is amazing.
When I think about
right now on Think Media
that we get around 2000 views
every hour on our content.
That's because, I was consistent for years
as a solo creator making videos.
And then now, as we built up a
team and scaling our company,
we're even more consistent.
We're in the middle of a
three-day, 10 hour a day,
batch shoot day which we're
already getting into tips,
to get as much content as possible
so that we can stay
consistent for months to come
in other areas of our business.
And so consistency matters
and tip number one is actually
you just have to decide
to actually make YouTube a priority.
Focus on the reward and think
what would it be worth to you
to have 2000 views every hour.
And it doesn't have to be that many.
We were talking with Omar
in the Think Media team
who helps a local business
that is a Lash company that is crushing it
and they were getting,
as they were starting
their YouTube channel,
they were getting 50 views an hour,
then 500 views an hour
or every couple of days.
4000 views every couple of days.
For their local business that
has a couple Lash stores,
not only were they doing Lashes
but they were also selling
Lash products online
and then they're also doing workshops
to train up Lash artists.
Their podcast is building momentum.
We have a whole thing from
Grow With Video this last year
on video podcasting
and that's one of the
things he helps them with.
They had to decide to
make YouTube a priority.
It takes energy, it takes time.
It takes them blocking
some time on their calendar
but it's really, the
question is not an issue
of whether you have time or not.
We all make time for the
things that we prioritize,
that actually matter to us and
so the last thing I'd say is
that it's a mindset shift
from dabbling to dominating.
I think that a lot of us
when it comes to YouTube,
we just are dipping our toes
in the water a little bit.
We're like okay, let me
just kind of drop a video,
see how it does then focus
on some other things.
Okay, let me do some...
we actually haven't made the commitment,
the decision to really say,
come hell or high water,
I'm getting a video out a week.
I'm gonna, I'm gonna figure out a way,
I'm gonna figure out to
block time in my calendar,
I'm gonna figure out shooting
a lot of videos all at once.
I'm gonna dip into my resources,
I'm gonna spend money
on staying consistent.
Whether that's hiring a babysitter
or whether that's hiring
a videographer to help you
or whether that's paying
for something else,
renting an Airbnb for a
weekend to shoot a bunch...
like by actually just making the decision
and what's amazing about the human spirit,
what's amazing about
what we're capable of,
everybody watching and
listening to this, is that
when we do make a resolute
decision, we will find a way.
That's why the phrase is:
where there is a will, there is a way.
You gotta will it, you gotta
decide and you gotta commit.
- Whoo! I'm already feeling convicted.
I'm ready, I'm ready
to dominate (laughing).
All right, so number two is
like you said, dedicate resources.
Man, this is a struggle sometimes.
We hear this a lot in our community.
We have business owners who
are making six, seven figures
and trying to do video on their own?
So tell us about how to stay consistent
by dedicating resources to YouTube.
- Yeah, I think that one of the blocks,
There's, there's two sides to this.
You know, some people
that watch Think Marketing
are in that Side Hustle Season,
and so their biggest
resource they have is time.
So they're trying to do it all.
They are a cook, bottle
washer, you know, janitor,
they're doing it all.
And, and then on the flip
side, though there are those,
and it was crazy,
we had a bunch of people
come to Vegas recently,
to our mastermind,
that are doing multiple
six figures a year,
high six, seven figures a year
and they're trying to learn video editing.
And it's like they've
got a core competency.
They are terrible video editors,
they've never done it in their life
and they're trying to add a new skillset.
If you need to do that
then you've gotta do that.
But you start thinking
well what if you just
dedicate some of your money
and so that you can buy back time.
It makes me think, we've
mentioned him a couple of times
on the Think Marketing show
but Roger, the expert plumber,
he has got a seven
figure plumbing business.
He made a commitment to dominate YouTube.
A commitment to fire his marketing company
and shift his dollars
towards modern marketing.
YouTube is free in the way he's using it.
But what he did was he hired
basically a full-time person
to help him focus on shooting that content
and editing that content.
The resources could be anything.
You need to dedicate some time.
You need to block time on your schedule.
When Omar's working with the
Lash company that he helps,
like they still have to,
in their busy schedule,
block the time to sit down,
record video podcast episodes with him,
invest in preparing that content.
It's not just the money,
it's the time, the energy,
the mental resources but
the payoff is invaluable
but they gotta dedicate that time.
You gotta dedicate the resources,
you gotta dedicate the energy.
My wife, we're talking and (mumbles),
was talking to a young
entrepreneur couple,
and then she was actually kind of talking
about our Side Hustle Season.
Like how do you do it?
Like what do you do when
sometimes you, you know,
you don't get to see Sean
every single night of
the week or whatever?
She said well I do get to see him.
Like he works from home,
and even he would come home every night.
But, because we had a
dream for our future,
like he had to put in
work, after his day job
he would come home and
work on his dream job.
She's like, how are you okay with that?
Because we had a vision for our future,
because we were willing to
sacrifice in this season,
because we said this is gonna take
some of our resources, that's time.
This is gonna take some
of our relationship time
and when it's come to our
marriage even those seasons,
you can still go on a date night every...
people got so much more time
than they realize they have.
You can still go on a date night,
still take like Sunday off,
take some time off on the weekends.
You don't have to watch six
hours of TV when you get home.
And some people are like I don't watch TV.
You don't have to play
four hours of Fortnite
and then watch YouTube for two hours
and then complain to your
sister for another two hours.
You, you get to choose what you're do...
you can put some of those blocks of time
into creating content for YouTube.
So whatever is your resources,
you've gotta get the time on the calendar,
you gotta figure out the
money and it comes back
to knowing that the payoff is there
when you invest in something
wise for growing your
business like YouTube, there is a return
but not if you don't
put that investment in.
- In celebration of the launch
of this brand new podcast,
we're giving away two tickets
to our annual conference,
Grow With Video Live, a 1500 dollar value.
- All you have to do to enter
is make sure you subscribe,
leave us a review on Apple podcast
and then take a screenshot of your review
and go to ThinkMarketingShow.com
for the rest of the details.
- Yeah so tip number three is really
putting in that work, so talk about that.
- Yeah, so then you
gotta dive in and start
and, you know when it comes
to staying consistent,
the you know, journey of a thousand miles
starts with a single step.
And so I think for some we also,
sometimes we're not
inconsistent because we
it's not that we don't believe in it
and it's not even that we're unwilling
to spend our time or our money.
It's actually that we're still kind of
stuck in hesitation mode,
in analysis paralysis,
in overthinking it, you know,
we're kind of stuck in our own heads.
And so you gotta just punch
fear in the face and start.
And just start posting videos.
Like we've often said: your first videos
are gonna be your worst videos.
And I think that's where we
get held back as influencers,
as leaders, as business owners,
because we're like: man, I
know, like I watch this person
who's been doing it for years
and, and I'm not gonna be that good.
Well of course you aren't.
Like nobody who starts anything
is great when they start.
You have to be willing
to suck at the start.
You have to be willing to be imperfect
and practice in public
and I really feel like
creating content on YouTube
is kind of like going
to the gym, same thing.
The decision, number one to get in shape
is something that you have
to make and not just like
oh, it's a New Year's resolution
and by the second week, that's everyone,
we've all done that,
and then there's no results a month later.
You actually decide, I'm gonna,
no matter what, I'm gonna do this.
And then you're gonna dedicate resources.
I'm buying the gym membership,
I'm actually going to put time
to work out three days a week.
But the next step is to
actually show up to the gym
and start lifting something heavier
than what you've normally
been carrying around.
Problem is, when you first walk in,
it's the worse experience ever.
Clearly, I've not actually
been to the gym very often,
I do run a lot but that's why,
you know things are scrawny
and I'm not actually lifting
anything therefore...
but when I have been to the gym,
there was one time two
years ago, Fitness 19,
a few, you know, blocks
away from here in Vegas
and I had this low dollar membership.
By the way, you kind
of get what you invest.
It was like a $19 dollars
a month membership,
that's why I stopped going back
and I didn't even cancel it.
I was like, just 19 bucks, whatever.
But when I walked in
there, I was like shoot,
I don't got any of the cool
swaggy workout clothes.
I'm kinda flabby, I'm out of shape.
If I even try to lift this weight,
my arms are gonna, you know...
And I don't know the form right
on these machines, it sucks.
You don't, you're not strong yet,
you, you don't have the momentum yet,
you don't have the confidence yet,
you don't have the form yet.
The same is true for YouTube.
You gotta just dive in and start
and everybody who either
has put in the work for physical fitness
or hasn't still understands that
that's the way the process works.
That if you keep showing
up a couple times a week,
three months later, six months
later, nine months later.
Now I think about in running,
I was like, when I first,
I could barely run around the block.
Now I'm like all custom shoes
and like my, you know I just
finished the half-marathon
after like doing a two-day seminar.
And like, and it's just kind
of become part of my life
'cause I've grown into it.
You've gotta just start and you
will get stronger as you go.
It can seem overwhelming
and heavy right now,
you'll get stronger.
So just start.
- Hmm that is so invaluable,
that lesson for me
has been the catalyst to be able
to start creating content on the platform
because it allowed me to understand
that it's okay to start messy.
That's one of the messages
that we say over at Think Media
and at Growth Video Live.
That is so important to just know
that it's okay to start messy
and I love how you said you gotta
be okay to suck at the start.
I mean, we're just starting
this, Think Marketing.
We had a plan but this is gonna progress,
this is gonna grow and
we came to the agreeance
that it was okay to just start,
to just get some momentum,
to just get it going
and so I love that tip.
And so tip number four is I
know, one of your passions
which is to never stop learning.
- Yeah, I mean, I think that
if you want to stay consistent,
what worked yesterday
just won't work today.
It's like true for every...
I mean, you're a parent?
- Hmm hmm
- and you've probably learned that man,
at certain seasons we've had some rhythm
with the kids, things have been going well
but then something will change.
- Always, every year.
- And you're like:
(mumbles) Hey! That used to work!
Why is that not working anymore?
'Cause what worked yesterday
won't necessarily work today.
And so we always have to be
learning and leveling up.
We realize that lifelong
leaders are lifelong learners.
And so what I mean is
it's not just accepting
that the way we got content done this year
is gonna work next year.
At Think Media, at our company here,
we need to always be evolving
so we're trying to learn
faster ways of speeding up.
This is a company culture thing by the way
so we, Omar on the Think Media team
is like a ninja at this.
Where we used to think that okay,
the way we would capture
footage and edit the footage
and upload the footage,
that had to take a day
or that had to take a couple of days
well now he's doing things
where it takes minutes.
Like he's compressing like minutes
or, or he's compressing
weeks into moments.
It's like super crazy but it's
'cause he continues to learn.
Learning a new way to do
it, a faster way to do it.
That's why we also invest in gear,
learning or how to use the gear better.
'Cause we're always learning you have to,
you never want to stop learning.
I just mentioned the
running analogy, you know,
running for me has become a habit,
and I can run and go further,
faster than when I started
because I do it every week but
I invest in getting better.
The momentum I'm creating is
'cause now I watch YouTube
videos on how to run
and I'm figuring out things about
how my feet work or whatever.
And then I'm getting stronger
but I'm also studying.
I'm watching documentaries
on it and reading books.
I just ordered a book on, on
how to run further, faster
and all these different
things 'cause I keep learning.
That's what we have to do to
stay consistent on YouTube.
Learn how to be faster
in optimizing our videos.
We use tools like vidIQ,
helps us optimize the videos faster.
Learn how to use Studiobater.
That's what a lot of
our programs are about
because we understand
how little time we have
and how much we have to
juggle as business owners
so it's just a matter of resourcing.
So the way you do it today,
you're maybe doing it a little bit slower.
That's why more people, some people can
pack in more working out in an hour.
I'm the type of guy, we're
on this workout analogy.
When I go to the gym it's
like do a few bicep curls,
check my phone for 10 minutes,
you know like do a few more.
And then you see somebody who's
doing like circuit training.
They just got like a week's of working out
compared to what you did in 40 minutes,
done while you were there.
It's the same hour that each person had
but because that person
has built that muscle,
developed that habit and continued
to level up their form, their
breathing, their coaching,
you know, taking their
game to another level,
that's how you stay consistent
and go further, faster on YouTube
by never stopping learning.
- That is so good and if
you are ready to dive in,
if you're ready to go
deeper in your knowledge
and you wanna be consistent on YouTube,
I encourage you to checkout
our Video Marketing Conference
that we have every year here in Las Vegas.
You can go to GrowWithVideoLive.com.
Sean, like give us just a snapshot
of what's gonna be happening this year
at Grow With Video Live.
- Yeah, this year at Grow With Video Live,
it's two and a half days,
middle of the week in Las Vegas,
so it's a Tuesday, Wednesday, Thursday.
At the Sahara which is a super cool hotel,
they just remodeled the entire thing.
We've got our Conference
Center locked there,
and there's gonna be some
incredible guest speakers
and it's gonna be, we're,
we're just excited because
there's a lot of great video
marketing conferences out there
but nobody that's kind of coming at it
with the approach that we have and that is
we wanna bring you the
latest and best strategies,
but here's the big key: we
want to avoid overwhelm.
A lot of the things we
noticed in some conferences
is that they've got 30 speakers,
45 speakers, 65 speakers
and you can come away with like:
Wow, I learned a lot but what
am I supposed to do next?
And so we curate the entire schedule
because we're so passionate about not...
complexity is the enemy of execution.
Like when you're just overwhelmed
and you have too much information,
you end up doing nothing.
That you get the right
information, the best information
from proven experts but
not just the information,
also the mindset.
And I think that's something
that we just care so much
about here, at Think Media
and that is that, you know,
what we've learned from
studying psychology
that actually success
is about 20% the tactics, the strategies,
the how to, the map and
that's an important 20%.
We have so much content and
energy we devote to that.
But honestly, success is about 80%
the actual mindset of taking action.
And isn't that true?
It's not so much that we don't
know, what we need to do.
It's punching fear in
the face and doing it.
It's actually taking our
game to another level
by taking our thinking to another level.
And overcoming some of those blocks
and getting confident to be on camera,
getting confident to
lead at a bigger level
and build a team, and build momentum,
and really lean in these
platforms, and take some risks,
and put yourself out there,
and deal with the haters.
So our speakers are mixed for that
so that you have a balance of
the latest and best strategies
as well as the mindset and actual experts
that can help us take
our game to another level
in every area and that's
probably the final thing as well
that we just kind of
have a holistic approach
'cause that's our DNA.
That it's not just, what
are the best YouTube tips.
There's, there's conferences
for just YouTube tips.
It's what is the bigger picture
and how do you actually scale
a high-impact, purpose-driven business
leveraging digital
marketing, and social media,
and these modern tools.
And so Grow With Video,
I think the biggest thing
if you go to GrowWithVideoLive.com
you get to see
some of the past videos
and kind of get a feel for
how our conference is
different than anybody else
in the industry.
And we love, I speak
at like, I don't know,
about 25 conferences this
past year and I love them all
and, and, and getting to
go to those different ones
it kind of gave me a point of view of
how we could create
something different that is
not just giving people
the right information
but also activating leaders
to take massive action
and go get results and
that's what we've seen
from so many in our community
that attend Grow With Video Live.
- Grow With Video is one of the
most incredible conferences.
If you're going to do anything
moving forward in the 21st Century.
In order to reach people,
you need to be utilizing video
and social media platforms.
- It was groundbreaking for me
and it helped me to
realize that I'm not alone.
- I like the practical
because I wanna know
what are my next steps and how is it
that we're going to reach the community
and the audience that
we're trying to build.
And you get that here
in every single session.
- Your mind is going to
be blown, I guarantee it.
- Tickets for Grow With Video
Live 2020 are on sale now.
Go to GrowWithVideoLive.com
for all the details and to claim yours.
- Thanks for checking out this episode,
we hope you got a ton of value
and if you haven't already,
subscribe here to the Think Marketing Show
wherever you're watching or listening.
- And hey, it would mean the world to us
if you would rate and review
this show on Apple Podcast.
- As we grow this movement of
purpose-driven content creators,
we encourage you to share with a friend
and we'll see you in the next episode.
(dramatic music)